We have this sense that survival
is like, "Hold on to your hat,"
right?
"Here it comes."
I don't think of it that way.
I'm a former Air
Force SERE instructor,
which is survival, evasion,
resistance, and escape.
We are the people who
teach our soldiers what
to do if they come
down behind enemy lines
and they want to
get back home again.
Over my 30 years or so,
of teaching these skills,
this is really the most
consolidated version I've done,
and many of the skills you're
going to see me doing here,
I've never done
anywhere else on camera.
The core of the class is going
to revolve around the five
basic needs of a survivor.
Signaling, personal protection,
sustenance, navigation,
and health.
We'll talk about what to do
before you leave on a trip, how
you should be thinking
about things before you
enter into the wilderness.
Then we're going to
make a survival kit.
Day hikes are the
most dangerous,
because we don't tend to
take that much with us.
What I put in a survival
kit can literally
make the difference
between life and death
if I find myself stuck out
there for a longer period.
In a survival
situation we need to be
able to think rationally
and not panic.
A key way to do this is
simply make your exhales
longer than your inhales, and
when things start to go wrong
my number one priority
is to get out of here,
so signaling needs
to be A-number one.
If your mind was going
through, oh, I need water,
I'm going to need a fire,
those are all secondary.
We can go, typically,
about 30 days without food,
and on average, about
three days without water.
When I was a kid growing
up I had some abuse issues.
And as I got older, I would
start to sneak out of the house
when I would have
nightmares and flashbacks.
I didn't want to be in a house
that didn't feel safe to me.
I wanted to go outside,
and I'd go climb a tree.
That was my safe zone.
The wilderness is so amazing
to help us be capable,
competent human beings.
What I really want
you to understand
is that the wilderness
is not out to get you.
She's not this creature that's
hovering and just waiting
for an opportunity to pounce.
So relax that mindset,
and go out there
and play, and learn
these techniques.
It'll open up a whole
new world for you.
I'm Jessie Krebs, and
this is my MasterClass.